let's talk about the best meal to
actually clean out your arteries and I'm
talking about
atherosclerotic plaquing this is some
new information that I think will
actually blow you away and you can apply
this to a lot of different body problems
and since heart attacks are the number
one killer I think you're going to be
glad that you watch this I was studying
some research involving germ free mice
because they do a lot of experiments on
animals that are germ free and like what
is this germ free thing right well
there's a way to grow an animal without
any microbes living on or inside them
and so they're really kind of a sterile
animal and that way they can do various
experiments and keep the microbiome out
of the picture now the question is can
an animal live germ free well yes they
can survive but I think they don't
survive very well first of all they
require a lot more nutrient dense foods
to survive because they don't have the
help from the microbes they have stunted
growth
underdeveloped Hearts lungs and their
liver is smaller they even have low
cardiac output so their heart doesn't
work as well the lining on their
intestine is thinner and they also have
a lot of GI problems and their immune
system doesn't develop fully and they
have a lot of inflammatory conditions
and there's even atrophy of their lymph
nodes but other than that they do quite
well so now how does this relate to your
arteries well I started looking into the
connection between germ-free mice
research and what kind of effects that
can create on your arteries I want to
see if there's any connection between
this lack of microbiome or dysbiosis and
your arteries and I found all sorts of
amazing amazing data when you start to
destroy the microbes in the gut actually
in my studies or basically have a
germ-free mouse they develop a lot of
inflammation throughout the entire body
including the arteries which is the kind
of the trigger of this whole Cascade of
effects that happens in the arteries
with plaquing and some people still have
this concept that
our blood is sterile okay we have no
microbes in our blood it's completely
sterile it's not there are
microorganisms living in your blood in
fact there are pathogens living inside
your plaque in the arteries yes
pathogens I'm talking about chlamydia H
pylori staphylococcus those pathogenic
microbes are living inside that plaque
and you have a lot of other microbes
inside the arteries too I mean think
about how many microbes we have in our
guts living on our skin why wouldn't we
have them throughout our organs well we
do and so apparently if there's an
imbalance in the microorganisms in our
body it can lead to all sorts of
problems in Our arteries now the other
piece of this puzzle that I want to
bring up now is there's this one very
specific important nutrient okay it's a
vitamin that has this responsibility of
keeping the calcium buildup out of the
arteries because when you have plaquing
you have inflammation you have calcium
and you have cholesterol plaques right
well this vitamin which you may already
know is called vitamin K2 and its job is
to keep the calcium out of the arteries
okay it directs the calcium back into
the bone and if you're deficient in
vitamin K2 you could actually build up
this calcium in the arteries now the
reason I'm bringing up K2 is because
guess what makes vitamin K2
microbes your own gut makes vitamin K2
it has the ability to convert the
vitamin K1 from leafy greens to vitamin
K2 vitamin K2 is in fermented foods
because the microbes the bacteria in
those fermented foods can make vitamin
K2 especially fatty fermented foods like
fatty cheese okay which is a fermented
product the fattier the cheese the more
vitamin K2 you're going to get and other
fatty things too like fatty meats you
can get it from salmon salami which is a
fermented product certain sausages
especially fatty pork sausage has
vitamin K2 up to five times other types
of sausage even certain hot dogs and
even bacon can have K2 in it now of
course you also have sauerkraut is
loaded with vitamin K2 and and yogurt
this is interesting because
what does the mainstream medicine tell
you to do to prevent this plaquing avoid
saturated fats avoid all these
cholesterol foods that have apparently
K2 which is like the antidote to this
calcium buildup and there's a great test
that you can do is called a CAC test
stands for
coronary artery calcification test and
it is one of the best predictors of
heart failure okay it's the amount of
calcium in your arteries it's a
relatively inexpensive test you can go
get it done and it'll actually give you
a good idea of where you are on the
stage of this problem if you were going
to take vitamin K2 as a supplement it
works better with vitamin D3 okay you
want to take those together and the
ratio would be this every 100 micrograms
of K2 you want 10 000 IUS of vitamin D3
but this is what you need to know
probiotics are
atheroprotective they protect you
against this hardening of the arteries
and this calcium buildup and this plaque
information your friendly microbes are
your natural probiotics the microbes in
your gut actually can eat fiber from
your vegetables and make certain things
as a byproduct and one of the things
they make is small chain fatty acids
which they basically is a type of fat
that helps lower insulin and helps
regulate your blood sugars which can
also help decrease the inflammation in
the arteries now the whole point of this
video
is to take a look at your diet from the
viewpoint
of
are you living on germ-free sterile
Foods okay I'm talking about pasteurized
Foods you have pasteurized milk you have
pasteurized juice everything is cooked
for shelf life we eat foods from boxes
right on the Shelf canned foods radiated
Foods that's right they use radiation to
kill off microbes so they will last
longer on the Shelf I mean just go to
the grocery store and just look on the
shelves you will find
so many sterilized Foods it's insane and
also we cook our Foods we cook the heck
out of our foods and we basically kill
off all the microbes we don't eat a lot
of raw foods anymore and on top of that
we're eating animals that had
antibiotics you have to realize that one
of the big side effects from antibiotics
is that now you have this dysbiosis
when you kill off microbes you kill off
the good microbes with the bad microbes
and the microbes that survive become now
resistant and now you have all sorts of
additional side effects one being
inflammation and if you're eating
animals that have antibiotics could that
have an effect on your body I think to
some degree again when you eat raw foods
and I'm talking about like plants like
microgreens that have been grown on soil
or or really healthy plants from your
garden there are a lot of microbes in
those raw plants that you're getting as
well and they can be considered almost
like a probiotic as well and if someone
really understands that concept they're
going to start eating more fermented
foods right and there are a lot of
different fermented foods fermented
vegetables is a great source of these
friendly microbes because not only are
you getting more microbes as an
inoculation to your existing microbiome
but you're getting kind of this
pre-digested food that's easier to had
digest and the worse off your digestive
system is the more you should have those
type of foods so let's Circle back and
take a look at what would be a really
good meal that would help with your
arteries okay and also this meal that
I'm going to talk about is pretty
contraintuitive if if you match it up
against mainstream medicine for this
problem because we're going to pack this
meal with the fattiest cheese talking
about brie cheese combined with fatty
pork sausage and of course sauerkraut
which you know I'm sure that's
acceptable by the mainstream medicine
these other two ingredients probably are
not but just think about what you're
getting when you have these three things
together
first of all each one of them is loaded
with vitamin K2 secondly you're getting
something else all three of these are
fermented which means bacteria has acted
on these foods to enhance
the availability of nutrients the
digestibility of these products are much
better because they're fermented and
each one of them are not sterile they
have microbes that you can use in your
own body so the next time you're at the
grocery store start looking at the foods
from the Viewpoint of how many foods are
actually sterile pasteurized over
processed and make a shift to start
buying foods that are more alive more
fermented more enhanced with this
fermentation process so since we're on
the topic of plaquing there's more to
learn about this and I put this video up
right here check it out